I think as a white woman of privilege who is a US senator running for president United States it is also my responsibility to lift of those voices that aren't being listened to and I can talk to those white women in the suburbs that voted for Trump and explained to them what white privilege actually is that when their son is walking down a street with a bag of M&Ms in his pocket wearing a hoodie his whiteness is what protects him from not being shot has a car that breaks down and he knocks on someone's door for help and the door opens and the help is given it's his whiteness that protects him from being shot that is what white privilege in America is today and so my responsibilities to not only lift up those stories but explain to communities across America like I did in Youngstown Ohio to a young mother that this is all of our responsibilities and that together we can make our community stronger thank